[Musique]
salut tout le monde c'est Noël vous le
savez en ce moment et pour fêter ça j'ai
décidé de faire une vidéo qui n'a rien à
voir avec
[Musique]
Noël 1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
r venez voir on a trouvé quelque chose
j'arrive quoi qu'est-ce qu'il a mon
chapeau alors qu'est-ce que c'est ça en
fait c'est un téléviseur ça permis
d'afficher des images qu'on a pu encoder
électriquement et qu'on diffuse un tube
catholique mais c'est pas la question
regardez plutôt ce que ça affiche c'est
c'est un dinosaure non c'est pas un
dinosaure ça c'est un jeu vidéo ça je
sais bien que c'est un jeu vidéo ça
c'est un
dinosaure bon ben je vaistirer ça vous
voulez pas m'aider je
suppose
[Musique]
fa Jurassic Park c'est juste mon film
préféré en fait je l'ai vu tellement de
fois je serais capable de vous réciter
le script en entier il y a eu une
floppée de jeu sur ce film et sur
quasiment tous les support quand on
achète un jeu Jurassic Park on s'attend
quand même à un minimum de qualité hein
de la part du meilleur film de tous les
temps après tout c'est normal c'est vrai
que la plupart du temps ces jeux-là
étaient très bons c'est vrai aussi que
des fois il était un peu moins allez
commençons rapidement par passer sur
quelques jeux jurassiic Park très connu
Jurassic Park sur supernest un jeu qu'un
fan m'a redonné puisque moi je l'avais
plus c'est probablement le plus connu et
aussi peut-être le meilleur des jeux
Jurassic Park ce jeu était extrêmement
difficile à boucler à cause de l'absence
totale de mot de passe qui est en fait
obligé à laisser la console allumer
pendant des jours si tu voulais le finir
mais bon à part ça il était tout
simplement excellent il fallait explorer
l' il on ramassé des œufs on insultait
Timy qui vous gonflait avec ses
galiminus on rentrait dans des bâtiments
en vue FPS d'ailleurs c'est con de le
dire mais moi la vieux FPS quand j'étais
gosse ça me faisait flipper quoi c'est à
cause de ça que j'usais pas y jouer au
début heureusement les Raptors étaient
très très cons et se contentaient de te
regarder de loin sans rien faire salut
alors comme ça tu es tu es un dinosaure
hein d'accord ah c'est bien d'ailleurs
je doute que beaucoup de gens on eu la
patience de le finir sur console parce
que c'est vrai que tu étais complètement
perdu tu savais jamais vraiment où il
fallait aller allez il y avait bien tes
potes qui te donnaient des indices mais
par contre à aucun moment tu les vois
pour t'aider c'est limite si en passant
à côté d'un bâtiment tu les entends pas
faire la fête pendant que toi tu risques
ton cul
dehors attrape les Raptors récupère les
ufs des Raptors remets les machines en
route attends j'ai un peu le sentiment
de me faire exploiter
là alors bref si comme moi vous faisiez
partie des gens qui n'avient encore
jamais fini Jurassic Park je vais vous
épargner cette peine voilà la
cinématique de fin de Jurassic Park sur
Super Nintendo
ouais c'est l'intro à l'envers j'ai bien
fait de pas le finir en fait quand
j'étais gosse Jurassic Park sur Master
System de la plateforme classique on
avance et on tue des dinosaures tout
simplement oui je c'est on dirait des
péqu en mort mais c'est bien des
dinosaures il y a trois types d'armes
différentes une qui tire vers le bas une
qui tire droit et une qui tire vers le
haut et on doit changer d'arme en
fonction du type d'ennemi en appuyant
sur
START sur START ouais sur le Start qui
est sur la console qui est à 3 m de vous
chaque fois que vous voulez changer
d'arme vous êtes obligé de vous déplacer
jusqu'à la console pour appuyer sur
START parce que je vous rappelle qu'il y
a pas de Start sur les manettes de
Master System comment est-ce qu'ils ont
pas pensé à ça vous croyez que j'ai
vraiment que ça à [ __ ] moi de déplacer
toute mon installation et de bouger tous
les câbles juste pour jou j un
jeu en fait il faut changer d'arme
tellement souvent qu'au bout d'un moment
je debout à côté de la console et là
encore comme dans le jeu sur supernest
les Raptors léger problème
neuronal Jurassic Park sur megga drive
alors pourquoi est-ce que je reviens sur
ce jeu alors que je l'ai déjà abordé
dans une autre émission c'est parce
qu'en réalité ce jeu c'est deux jeux
différents il y a la partie avec grand
et la partie avec le Raptor moi quand
j'étais GAM j'étais très fan de ce jeu
déjà parce que c'était un de mes
premiers jeux Jurassic Park et même si
le jeu était bourré de problème on s'en
foutait c'était pas important on jouait
le Raptor on était le méchant de
l'histoire c'était le seul truc qui
compait j'ai lu d'ailleurs que beaucoup
de gens en fait faisaient comme moi et
ne jouent quasiment qu'à la partie avec
le Raptor faut dire que la partie grande
elle elle était beaucoup plus banale
vachement plus difficile et vraiment
surtout beaucoup plus frustrante donc
cette partie donc vous contôlez grand
qui se retrouve éjecté en bas de la
route après s'être fait attaquer par le
T-Rex monsieur je vous lave la vitre
évidemment de grimper les 3 mètres qui
le séparent de la route décide de partir
à travers la jungle qui est rempli de
dinosaures et comme ça suffit pas plutôt
que de faire une simple ligne droite il
va aussi s'amuser à faire un méga détour
histoire d'aller visiter l'intérieur
d'un volcan en éruption un jour il
faudra quand même expliquer pourquoi les
héros de jeu vidéo sont tous des
idiots bref on rencontrera donc
principalement trois types de dinosaures
les dilophosaures les
Raptors ça doit faire mal ça et les
compis d'ailleurs c'est assez concept de
voir que les petits dinosaures en fait
sont plus intelligents que les humains
quand tu joues le
Raptor le jeu en lui-même est pas
spécialement dur he c'est juste qu'il y
a une chose qui le rend hyper gonflant
c'est ça les chutes mortelles tout le
temps à tous les niveaux parce que c'est
ça c'est ça c'est exactement ça ma
raison de pas jouer avec gr dès que vous
faites une chute d'une certaine hauteur
peu importe si vous avez votre barre
d'énergie pleine le jeu considère que
c'est une chute mortelle et ça ça arrive
tout le TS prenez le tout début du
niveau 2 il y a une échelle juste ici
qui te permet de monter ok il y a bien
un dinosaure audessus mais bon hein je
risque quoi bon au pire je veux dire je
tombe de l'échelle je retombe juste en
bas mais non non non non non non tu
meurs simplement c'est quel est le but
de mettre une échelle ici si tu ne peux
que mourir en la
prenant mais bon niveau chute quand tu
fais le jeu pour la première fois le
pire ça reste quand même le niveau 3 je
veux dire c'est absolument impératif de
connaître par cœur le trajet parce que
peu importe la hauteur de laquelle vous
tombez si votre zodiaque heurte le sol
vous êtes mort même ça [ __ ] non mais
comment je meurs là franchement non mais
je je me suis noyé dans quoi là dans une
flaque dans de la pelouse humide en je
je je sais bien que c'est un jeu vidéo
mais là c'est n'importe quoi la merde
faites gaffe monsieur by la pelouse est
mouillée
[Musique]
quoi même en tombant de 1 m de haut vous
crevez en reculant là doucement
doucement
ouais tu veux tomber tiens regarde vas-y
tombe il fallait pas toucher la manette
j'ai horreur de ça quand mais je me
prenne pour un con vous savez ce jeu je
l'ai fini que assez récemment en fait
parce que quand j'étais plus jeune
j'avais rien compris à la manière de
finir le boss de fin et ça que ce soit
avec le Raptor ou avec grand avec les
deux personnages la fin se passe au même
endroit que la scène du film et euh vous
vous vous savez un jour je devrais faire
un top 10 des des boss de fin les plus
débiles que j'ai vu mais là vraiment je
crois que celui-là il est très bien
placé bon ben allez en
avantin oui c'est c'est c'est ça c'est
bien ça il y a pas de bug là c'est ça
c'est le jeu c'est c'est la stratégie du
jeu je je jette des grenades explosives
devant leur nez pour faire tomber le
squelette et eux il le voient pas c'est
ça se finit comme ça c'est tout point
final et ben regardez même grand il lève
ép l' de dire attends c'est quoi cette
merde
là mais quand vous jouez un jeu comme ça
vous attendez quand même un minimum du
boss de fin ne serait-ce que d'affronter
le T-Rex tout simplement et là il y a
rien il y a rien c'est comme si imaginez
ça dans un film c'est comme si vous
faisiez monter l'intrigue et qu' avait
aucun dénouement c'est comme si dans
Titanic le bateau coulait pas qu'il
arrivait à New York et que le film
s'arrêta comme ça tranquillement
est arrivé en améri il s rien passé de
tout le voyage et on s bien fait chier
coucou tout le
monde
[Musique]
coucou allez c'est bien parce que c'est
Noël que le dernier jeu Jurassic Park
que je vais vous montrer est un jeu PC
depuis le temps qu'on me demande de
faire un jeu pc donc allez je vous fais
ce cadeau Jurassic Park 13 passeurs
sorti en 1998 ce j ait pu être vraiment
excellent il avait pas été truffé de bug
au lieu de ça on a là un magnifique
simulateur de randonnée où vous incarnez
Anne une ancienne nazie qui se balade
toujours le bras levé ça doit pas être
pratique de se déplacer comme ça quand
même et donc on atterrit sur une île
avec tellement de trucs pas cohérents
que je me suis demandé tout le long du
jeu si en fait j'étais pas sur l'île de
la séri lost non mais sérieusement déjà
le premier truc pourquoi tout est empilé
c'est genre les scientifiques se sont
dit merde les dinosaures se sont
échappés qu'est-ce qu'on fait ben on
empile les caisses bon ben ok Deol il
est censé être donné depuis quelques
années mais regardez les décors on
dirait que c'est là depuis des siècles
et troisième truc c'est les dinosaures
en fait qui ont incendié les voitures
qui ont volé les pneus qui ontvé les
moteurs qui ont renversé le car ou alors
c'est des Raptors c'est des racailles
ces dinosaures ils ont dû descendre là
de de la cité des Raptor là tu sais et
ils ont brûlé toutes les voitures de
lîle
[Musique]
voilà
non le jeu est rythmé par la voix de
John Amond qui tous les 20 mtres vous
raconte l'histoire de l'Î
ok moi au début je me suis dit bon oui
c'est une voix off c'est tout jusqu'à ce
que j'arrive
là attends attends Anne vient de
répondre à la
voix c'est quoi ça il est planqué dans
un
cocotier bon le premier truc assez
troublant dans ce jeu déjà c'est qu'il
n'y a pas d'interface dans un souci de
Ré votre compteur de vie s'affiche sur
votre nichon gauche sous la forme d'un
tatouage qui se remplit quand vous
prenez des coups voilà comme si c'était
réaliste d'avoir une nana avec des lolos
aussi gros qu'elle arrive même plus à
avoir ses pieds il y a des fois où c'est
pas très pratique
d'ailleurs c'est la poutre qu'il faut
regarder par contre vous attendez pas à
tuer des dinosaures par centaine parce
que c'est avant tout quand même un jeu
d'exploration enfin bon cela dit les
quelques dinosaures qu'on croise en
général sont souvent très très cons
dans ce jeu on a l'exemple typique de
l'intelligence artificielle qui marche
pas voilà celui-là il s'est assommé tout
seul c'est
bien non mais sérieusement il y a
vraiment un problème avec les dinosaures
de cette île je crois mais regardez ça
quoi ouais celui-là il a carrément pété
les plombs mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait
ah celui-là il insiste non non mais la
persévérance c'est une qualité même
quand on est con oh [ __ ] celui-là il
sort de boî il tient plus debout quoi
oui je me sens pas bien arrêtez de
bouger tous les
deux en fait ils sont tellement cons si
tu te sers d'un pauvre caillou comme
bouclier ils sont complètement déboussol
il savent plus quoi faire regardez là je
crois que j'ai le T car plus sur qu je
test qu fois les Raptors
sont vous avez
[Musique]
cré Lex contreiosa qui soit intelligent
et assez dangereux finalement non je
déconne c'est de la merde aussi ah il
est con comme un placard en
fait évidment faut toujours qu' Joh qui
vous raconte sa vie au mauvais
moment bon je fais quoi est-ce que je
vous parle des autres dinosaures
bon non c'est pas gentil de se moquer
des handicapés en fait d'ailleurs mis à
part ça vous l'aurez remarqué en fait
c'est une fusion entre paye le fille de
One Piece elle fait tout avec un bras
elle maîtrise toutes les armes de se
bras elle peut soulever des poutres de
200 kg elle plante ses ongles dans des
rochers pour les soulever elle peut même
allonger ses bras ou faire des rotations
complètes du poignet du coup j'ai voulu
chercher l'explication en trouvant un
cheit qui te permet de visionner ton
personnage à la troisème personne et là
la vérité éclate enfin an n'est en
réalité qu'un bras collé sur une paire
de sein femme parfaite quoi
euh après moi je dis pas être une femme
en Cachou ça a peut-être ses avantages
mais pour tenir une arm en tout cas
c'est horrible à chaque fois que vous
heurtez un mur une porte n'importe quoi
d'autre Anne lâche son arme non mais
vous vous rendez compte qu'en l'espace
de 15 m mon arme elle est tombé quatre
fois déjà non mais elle a du beur
tartiner sur les mains c'est pas
possible j'ai pas parlé des parties où
faut taper des digicodes oh [ __ ] c'est
comme vouloir taper un texto avec des
Gand box je crois j'ai jamais autant
rigolé ma vie en essayant allez an vas-y
allez allez vas-y concentre-toi non
[ __ ] les téléphones c'est
pareil et le pire c'est que ça marche en
plus merci de bien vouloir rester en
ligne nous recherchons votre
correspondant non j'attends c'est pas
comme si j'étais sur une île remplie de
dinosaures en fait que ce soit les bons
côtés ou les mauvais côtés du jeu en
fait tout vient à la base du moteur
physique qu'il faut quand même le
reconnaître par contre pour l'époque ce
moteur physique est exceptionnel le jeu
quand à lui est quand même assez long tu
te tapes deux forêts puis la montagne
une autre forêt tu arrives en ville
trouve une porte mais il te faut une
carte donc tu fouilles toutes les
maisons à la recherche de la carte
d'accès en laissant tomber ton arme à
chaque [ __ ] de porte tu trouves la
carte d'accès bleu mais maintenant on te
dit qu'il faut la carte d'accès rouge
[ __ ] la carte rouge te permet de
trouver la carte blanche la blanche te
permet de trouver la rose qui te permet
de trouver la jaune qui te permet de
trouver la verte qui te permet de
trouver une mtre violette le laissz
passer le cou des cartes d'accès de 30
couleurs différentes ça me dérange pas
je veux dire c'est dans dans tous les
jeux mais quand tu ramasses une carte tu
es obligé de te la trballer à bout de
bras qui en plus tombe à chaque fois que
tu heurtes un truc comme pour les armes
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai pitié mon
dieu mais pourquoi sur 3 milliards de
femmes la seule qui atterrit sur cette
île c'est une ther qui entend des voix
et qui a des [ __ ] de Pai au risin à
la place des mains enfin mais merde
c'est qu'une petite carte magnétique je
veux dire 50 endroit où elle pourrait se
la
mettre je pense aller brancher ce truc
là
moi voilà tu sais quoi je vais me tordre
le bras me tirer dans le genou et
arrêter là voilà
oui je sais c'était
prévisible qu'est-ce qu'on fout dans la
jungle je sais pas
ne bouge plus son acuté visuel est bé
sur le mouvement ça veut dire quoi
[Musique]
alors c'est vous et Lex sur une
plage le ballon
vous une bine B
AR c'est mon bureau en fait non parce
que c'est dommage parce que je
connaissais un super groupe de R
[Musique]